winter is coming and the only constant
thing is change Game of Thrones Season 5
episode 10 season finale mothers mercy I
was nervous going into this episode
because I went in going there isn't that
much left to do the season I mean
there's a you know storylines left to
tie up but it's gonna be jumping all
over the place time these things up most
of the things that haven't been
addressed in the last couple of episodes
of stuff I'm not that interested in
here's the odd thing it is more or less
what I thought it was gonna be tying up
with the various stories jumping all
over the place is not a particularly
focused episode but I actually still
like it I mean part of that has to do
with specific way certain stories go
some of it just has to do with the feel
of the episode overall which silly
that's hard to put my finger on but
there was an awful lot of closure to
this episode I mean you know something's
were obviously left open-ended to be
picked up next season I like the way
some stories end it a little bit better
than others but it really did feel like
this was a very firm chapter closing
moment at which obviously should but it
was a degree of overall closure that I
wasn't actually kind of expecting I was
expecting you a couple of small bits of
closure some cliff hangers and well no
there was some very clear firm nope
that's it for that to another story
lines and even the ones that didn't end
that definitively definitely this sort
of chapter in that story is done and we
got a nice pretty clean break for the
most part there's a couple of the
stories that the way they ended i'm like
i'm not sure what to what to make of
that either because of what happened to
the very end ER where that actually
leaves things to go next season but i
mean that's that's something i'm gonna
get into what i do my season overview
where i will finally be talking spoilers
but i do have to say for as rough a
season as this was for me and I des as
strong as the closing was and when I say
closing I mean the last few episodes and
this episode in particular I still think
this is probably my least favorite
season overall it's just getting to this
ending was really hard and really
painful but I mean that said the last
couple episode
and even this episode particularly it's
a good strong finisher it's probably my
second favorite season finale behind
season 4 still not a big fan of the
season overall but it does give me hope
that the show has not completely jumped
the rails because I did you know slog
through the stuff to get to good stuff I
don't know if it was necessary for us to
suffer the way we did first half of this
season in order to get to the good stuff
later on but it we did eventually get
there and I would rather end on a high
note having struggled to get there then
start grading and in a low place so if
those are my options this is the one I
prefer so I guess that about wraps it up
for this one I I guess since I said mine
what is your favorite season finale for
Game of Thrones so far whatever it is
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned